Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
some high-powered scholarships are
coming to some very deserving young
people in Nevada and to tell us more
about that we have Angel Williams from
NV Energy you guys have given away so
many scholarships through the public
Education Foundation over the years and
this year is no different yeah for more
than 20 years we've given out nearly 2
million dollars in scholarships to
graduating high school seniors and so
we're thrilled to bring back this year
our powerful partnership scholarship
program we're awarding up to 50 High
School seniors with a one thousand
dollar scholarship to a Nevada higher
education institution absolutely
phenomenal and you've been doing this
for so long have you heard from some of
the kids who over the years who have
received the scholarships we have we
have students that have stayed in state
and come back and pursue internship
opportunities with us and then go on to
graduate and they're doing fantastic
things in our community you know whether
they stay local or they go on to other
opportunities outside our state we're
grateful for that homegrown talent that
goes to school here and continues to
serve I think for a lot of parents
sometimes they don't know about such
great scholarships that are going on so
this is a really good opportunity to
tell kids and their parents how they can
apply for these scholarships if you
visit nvenergy.com scholarships you can
go there and you can find all the
criteria and information on how to apply
it's an easy online application you need
a minimum 3.0 GPA and some community and
volunteer service some school activities
are also helpful and you complete that
information there our deadline is
February 19th so still plenty of time
share that information with the students
in your life graduating high school
seniors who are looking for this year
I'm sure you get a lot of applications
we do we're fortunate enough to to be
able to bring the opportunity to a lot
of students but it's it's not too
competitive competitive of a process so
we encourage folks to apply absolutely
why not right why is it important for MV
energy are the folks there to get
involved and be involved like this in
the community community support is a
core value of NV Energy and our
foundation and our scholarship program
is one example of how we choose to give
back to the community and prioritizing
access to education particularly to
diverse communities is a strong priority
for us we're fortunate to also provide
support to non-profit organizations that
are reaching and serving youth an
example of that a favorite one of ours
is through the Latin Chamber of Commerce
Foundation the Latino youth leadership
conference or silver state equality they
have a wonderful youth leadership
advocacy group that connects students
from the lgbtq community with leadership
opportunities and again additional
educational support so there are so many
there are hundreds that we enjoy
supporting but providing access and
opportunity to students as Chief among
them well it is so greatly appreciated
where can people find the applications
that's nvenergy.com scholarship February
19th is that deadline all right let's
take a look at that information right
there if you have your phone real quick
grab that right there the QR code and if
you don't have that go to the website or
give that number a call if you want more
information we'll be right back